what happens
good evening everybody members and
guests
everyone who's joined us this evening
for this meeting of the overview and
scrutiny panel it's the 18th of january
2022
7 o'clock so we can make a start
the if the fire alarm is activated
please vacate the offices down the main
staircase opposite the lifts in the
foyer assembly uh is to be in hawley
square on the green
officers will assist you and advise you
when it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber
or even across the road i would imagine
looking at the folks that we've got out
there
would everyone please present if they've
got their phones with them ensure
they're not used to make or receive
phone calls or text messages
or any other
kind of mobile communication whilst the
meeting is in progress
this meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public and so we welcome
any members of the public who are
joining us this evening it will also be
recorded and subsequently broadcast on
the internet
uh does anyone here intend to film the
meeting
i can't see anybody so i think we can
skip over the filming details
um speaking uh item e uh speaking under
rule 20.1 i have requests to speak from
the foreign members
councillor ruth bailey
councillor helen whitehead and
councillor mike garner are there any
other members who wish to speak
under rule 20.1
um
thank you very much we will come to you
of course
public speaking i haven't received any
requests
the members of public have you just no
thank you
so we move then on to the
substantive part of the agenda dealing
with the apologies for
absence i have apologies from
uh councillor huxley who is being
substituted by councillor everett
welcome councillor eric uh councillor
pat moore being substituted by council
yates welcome councillor yates and we
have apologies from councillor coleman
cook are there any other
apologies to be registered
i'm going to check with my glasses cozy
thank you very much declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest members wish to make
on the items this evening
now this one is a a new one for me
because i wasn't actually here at the
last meeting so
i was unwell but our next
gender item is item three minutes of the
previous meeting to approve the minutes
of the overview and scrutiny panel
meeting held on the 23rd of november in
2021
as i say i wasn't here but can i have a
proposal please
thank you very much councillor reticon
and the seconder please
thank you very much councillor austin uh
do members agree
thank you very much
we are blessed this evening with the
presence of kent police who are with us
this evening can i welcome on your
behalf members and officers chief
inspector matthew smith who's going to
make a presentation
looking at the subject of modern slavery
in senet
so
chief inspector smith thank you very
much for coming you're very welcome we
look forward to hearing what you've got
to say and just as a by the way it's
entirely up to you if you keep the
mask on if you feel easier speaking
without it
please please do remove it if you wish
thank you very much uh good evening um
thank you for the invitation to come
here and speak this evening um i'll just
quickly introduce myself it's matthew
smith temporary chief inspector district
commander for thanet
i've been in post since october i'm
aware that i'm probably one of a number
of chief inspectors you might have seen
throughout your time here at thanet i've
been here since october and i'm here for
some months to come
my background prior to coming to fannie
is as a detective investigating serious
and complex crime across east division
domestic abuse hate crime and other
vulnerability associated offences
so i'm going to talk to you this evening
about human trafficking and modern
slavery in the thanet district and
provide some examples and case studies
of some partnership working
since my arrival in thanet
the presentation probably take about 15
minutes or so but please do prompt me if
i start going over and i'm going out of
time
so what we're seeing here on the board
is the kent control strategy and that is
uh the overarching strategy which
directs our police response towards
those crime types which cause the most
harm to the most vulnerable in our
communities
and it includes exploitation serious
violence abuse high harm crime and
counter-terrorism modern slavery and
human trafficking trafficking is on the
far left in the exploitation category
but actually it probably spans in its
most serious cases all of the control
strategy
and the centre of that is child centered
policing
uh ken police does have a dedicated
modern slavery and human trafficking
investigation team
out of the headquarters which works
alongside the national crime agency and
ensures safeguarding enforcement and
education around this subject local
cases are also investigated by the local
cid teams
across the division and at thanet also
our frontline and investigative
colleagues within kent police are all
trained to recognise the signs of modern
slavery and human trafficking some of
which i'll talk about throughout the
presentation we have had spec specific
training and there is a knowledge hub on
the kent police internet for officers to
refer to should they need to
the focus of chem police is to ensure
safeguarding and removal of those
victims being exploited while seeking
out those who prey upon the vulnerable
and bring them to justice
so when we say modern slavery and human
trafficking what do we actually mean
well the united nations defines modern
slavery
modern day slavery and human trafficking
as a recruitment transportation transfer
harboring or a seat of persons by
improper means for an improper purpose
including forced labor or sexual
exploitation
and the five categories which we refer
to are domestic servitude
forced criminality labour exploitation
organ harvesting and sexual exploitation
i'll just touch on those to put those
into context
so domestic work is a sector which is
particularly vulnerable to exploitation
and domestic slavery because of the
unique circumstances of working within a
private household combined with a lack
of legal protection
domestic workers perform a range of
tasks in private homes including cooking
cleaning laundry taking care of people
running errands and some domestic
workers also live in their employers
homes and are often considered to be on
call 24 hours a day
the pay is often very low with wage
payments frequently delayed
and some domestic workers may not
receive payment at all
and be kept in poor living conditions
with documents withheld such as their
passport
force criminality
that is a category which incorporates
a proportion of young people so people
under the age of 18 are classified as
children in the uk and therefore it's
not surprising to see many young people
get caught up in aspects of criminal
exploitation
children are particularly vulnerable to
exploitation by individual opportunists
traffickers and organized criminal
groups
but they're also
vulnerable to exploitation from less
sophisticated groups and more locally
based
groups such as those involved in county
lines drug supply
other forms of forced criminality are
counterfeit dvd selling bag snatching
atm theft pickpocketing
and cannabis cultivation to name a few
labour exploitation so that's forced
labor which is sometimes hidden but most
commonly occurs in plain sight victim
victims come from a variety of
backgrounds they may be uk citizens eu
migrants or those from outside the eu
people who are subject to forced labor
are typically made to work in areas such
as agriculture construction service
industry manufacturing and hospitality
they may also be victims of debt bondage
where they're tricked into working for
little or not no money to repay a debt
and
perpetrators will use different tactics
to trap the victim in an endless cycle
of debt which will never be repaid and
can even be passed on to their family
organ harvesting obviously sounds very
alarming but i can reassure you there's
not been a case of organ harvesting
reported in the uk but is used as a
threat towards victims to control them
it is unfortunately something that is
seen overseas
sexual exploitation is something that
can affect adults and children alike
when it comes to modern slavery and
human trafficking
and can be it can be defined as a person
deceived coerced or forced to take part
in sexual activity and when we're
talking about slavery in human
trafficking we're talking about
prostitution brothels escort agencies
massage parlors and the like
so on the presentation here are just
some of the many indicators that a
person may be a victim on modern slavery
uh there is a a long list but i've just
picked a few out here which some of you
may recognize
as i touched on before modern slavery
can happen in plain sight but there are
some things that we can all look out for
here
so as i touched on there people may
present without documents or documents
that are forced or forged they have a
lack of freedom of movement
they may be fearful and anxious or
withdrawn when talking to people in
position of authority probably because
they're under threat of being reported
to those authorities by the people
exploiting them
the people may appear to be working
under instruction
they may have to resort to crime in
order to eat due to receiving no money
they're unlikely to have an employment
contract be forced to work long hours
and poor conditions
may live within the workplace and not be
dressed adequately for the work they do
for example not being provided adequate
ppe
poor degrading living conditions
and may be forced to open bank accounts
or credit agreements they're just some
of the signs that may um and should
cause alarm bells to ring um should you
encounter
people displaying those signs because
they may well be victims of modern
slavery and human trafficking
so this slide here um is a breakdown of
reports of modern slavery and human
trafficking offences in thanet over the
last six months
there are a total of 12 offenses
reported in thanet during that period
they can be broken down into four cases
of criminal exploitation three of which
were drug supply
five labour exploitation cases including
two restaurants one nail bar
one shop and one general laboring
one sexual exploitation case which
related to a child exploitation
investigation
one case of domestic servitude
and one further case of suspected
trafficking of a victim that trafficking
didn't take place in thanet but due to
the method by which we report crime uh
this was somebody who traveled from
overseas and reported the offence
infante therefore ken police recorded
the offence in the thanet district
and to put that context those numbers
account for approximately 11 of the
recorded modern slavery human
trafficking offences for east kent
and it's for the reason i just outlined
in terms of where we record the offence
that dover for example may see a high
proportion of cases of human trafficking
because that's where the offence is
reported on a person coming into the
country despite the events taking place
elsewhere
so how have we been working with
partners um in thanet to safeguard
victims and investigate cases of modern
slavery and human trafficking
well as i said i've been planet district
commander since october and since that
time i've been really impressed with the
multi-agency partnership working across
various areas of policing
but including modern slavery in human
trafficking
three case studies of which i'll touch
on shortly
so the multi-agency task force is is a
really valuable tool a really valid
valuable asset
those partners you know thank district
council dwp kemp police fire and rescue
service social services gang master and
labour abuse authority hmrc to name a
few
all working together is a really
advantage
and one of the main advantages is the
ability to share information quickly and
reach joint decisions
with a joint agreed intended outcome so
that we can quickly safeguard potential
victims and disrupt and deter criminal
activity
another advantage of the joint working
is for the ability of different agencies
to use their own powers to tackle the
problem from different angles so hmrc
for example have different powers they
can rely on to chem police to hurt
criminals um financially
so as an example the dwp officer
embedded within the multi-agency task
force from the dwp economic serious and
organised crime team is a real advantage
as it allows for that real-time access
to information systems where there's an
immediate risk of threat rather than
immediate threat risk or harm or a
threat to life such as a high-risk
missing person links county lines which
may be linked to modern slavery
the dwp embedded officer is trained to
the same level as a detective so pip
level 2 is what we refer to which
provides an advantage in terms of
interview support
dealing with complex of benefit offences
which may come to light during the
course of our investigations and allows
us to work together as i say to tackle
this criminality from different angles
those cases which a joint worked on can
be progressed quickly with necessary
agencies involved at an early stage
which means a range of offences can be
reviewed using the specialist knowledge
of partners with agreements as to who's
going to take privacy of which part of
the investigation or with that common
goal of safeguarding victims
so as i'm sure we'll all agree
partnership working is key to policing
and community safety and this has
certainly been what i've seen in thanet
and i'm just going to touch on three
examples now of some partnership working
in relation to modern slavery and human
trafficking
the case studies i'm going to relate to
are current or recent investigations uh
i have therefore sanitized the specifics
of the locations and there are no names
of people involved but hopefully from
this you'll be able to get a flavor as
to the three cases that i'm talking
about
one was margate one was broad stairs and
one was ramsgate
so the first case study related to
some intelligence received that illegal
migrants are working and living in a
restaurant and they're subject to poor
paying conditions those warning signs
that i spoke about earlier and this was
some community intelligence that had
been received
so a multi-agency visit took place soon
after that intelligence was received and
that multi-agency visit included police
thanic district council licensing
fire rescue service the gang master and
labour abuse authority
and research and input intelligence from
the department of work and pensions
on attendance at the
location
we were allowed in without any
resistance but in the basement area six
rooms have been constructed and all
rooms were in occupation with beds
clothing and personal possessions found
thankfully no evidence or concerns in
relation to modern slavery and human
trafficking were reported at the time
by the persons present
however
coming back to that joint working kfrs
the fire and rescue service did serve a
restriction notice on the uh business
due to the unsafe living conditions
which meant that no persons can sleep in
the basement from that point forward due
to lack of fire escape fire safety for
example those people were at risk by
those living conditions
and we didn't just walk away and leave
it there it's obviously important to
follow that up so a further multi-agency
visit took place on the 3rd of november
with revenue in customs and police
and on that occasion two people located
during that visit were taken to margate
police station
and were interviewed by her majesty's
revenue customs due to their links to an
ongoing investigation
on these visits all victims were offered
safeguarding they were spoken to
privately through use of interpreters
where required to ensure they had the
opportunity to report any concerns or
offences
nobody at that stage reported being a
victim of modern slavery or human
trafficking
in those circumstances where somebody
doesn't
come forward and say they are a victim
but we believe there are sufficient
evidence or intelligence to say that
they are
we can refer them and their case into
the national crime agency without their
consent so we don't necessarily always
take somebody's word for it because we
do understand
through the fear and the coercion that
they may not uh feel in a position to
report that they are indeed a victim and
that makes it difficult when we're
looking at crime statistics nationally
it's difficult to measure how much human
trafficking modern slavery is ongoing
because victims are quite reluctant to
report it
the second case study
came from an investigation that was
taking place by our child protection
team at fanet they came across some
information which gave them concern that
a
food outlet was
putting young female employees at risk
of sexual and labor exploitation
again multi-agency meeting and a
multi-agency visit took place and that
took place in november 2021
excuse me
and during the joint visit uh kfrs fire
rescue service again took an inspect
undertook an inspection with regards to
safety aspect to that building
and several
areas of concern were found no smoke
alarms large quantity of cooking oil
stored general disrepair and leaks this
was an area where food
was cooked and prepared so clear clear
safety hazards there
of concerned one member of staff
appeared to be coached into providing
answers by another male who was the
manager
again it looks looking back to earlier
acting under instruction
that person was taken aside and spoken
to privately with the use of an
interpreter and they gave an
inconsistent account as to how they came
to the uk and what they were doing at
that premises
immigration officers conducted a check
and it was found that that person had a
current asylum application pending which
actually prevented him from working in
the uk
this person said that he knew that
working there was against his conditions
and he was removed from the premises and
the immigration are likely to issue the
manager of that premises with a
substantial fine regarding the
employment of that individual
as a result of that visit valuable
intelligence and information was
gathered is being taken forward by dwp
and hmrc
in a parallel investigation
again all victims are offered
safeguarding support and signposting to
those services which may assist them
however no offences were reported
the third case study um relates to
forced labor
and that was a call from a member of the
the public who'd had some uh
manual labor done at his property
and he was concerned for a member of the
traveller community uh within thanet
and the report was that the two males
had another male with them and they
appear to be working that person in a
way that was characteristic of modern
slavery
multi-agency uh task force began
investigation and through working with
the community safety partnership we
located the mail
within thanet in a noticeably run-down
accommodation in comparison to the the
other accommodation around him and
appeared to be isolated from the rest of
the community
it actually transpired that that
individual was wanted by police for a
fraud of over 50 000 pounds
so he was arrested however it did give
us that opportunity to remove him from
the situation
speak with him as a victim potential
victim of human trafficking modern
slavery
with an open mind of yes he might be a
suspect for an ongoing offence but also
he may be a current victim of modern
slavery
he declined to report any concerns to us
however we've shared the information
with the relevant authorities
so in summary despite no none of those
three instance reports resulting in
anybody declaring they're a victim of
modern slavery and human trafficking for
the reasons that i spoke about earlier
they they may well not have been but
also they may well have been reluctant
to
and what it does demonstrate is the
importance and value of partnership
working communication
and collaboration in order to respond
quickly to any concerns raised within
the senate district
the examples also demonstrate the value
of community intelligence reporting
those things which just don't seem right
that you're concerned about
in the community thinking about those
indicators i referred to earlier
so i just wanted to highlight a few ways
uh which
you or members of the community can
report concerns rather modern slavery
and human trafficking there is a modern
slavery helpline
that can be reported through the
national crime agency who are the lead
agency
it can be reported to the police by 999
of course in emergency 101 or on online
reporting
and crime stoppers is an option for
those who wish to remain anonymous
and we've also over the last couple of
days launched my community voice which
is a direct
communication method between members of
the community and the police
and they can report any concerns to
their local ward pcso or officer through
that method
and equally we will be using my
community voice to continue to share
the good work and praise that is ongoing
not only for the police but for our
partners
so hopefully that's given you an insight
as to the partnership approach to modern
slavery and human trafficking in the
senate and thank you for the opportunity
of sharing that with you this evening
chief inspector thank you very much uh
members of the members got questions or
comments you'd like to make
chief inspector smith
yes
council came please
[Music]
thank you yeah it was very interesting
i'm just always worried about all the
car wash people are they is that
legitimate are they there voluntarily
the car washes are one of the locations
that we uh so car wash is one of the
locations we do look at on our all out
days or days of action around one
slaving human trafficking
that is a
a place that is frequently used for
victims of modern slavery and human
trafficking uh i'm not aware of any
cases within the thanet district itself
but certainly nationally car washes is a
place where forced labor um
people are sometimes kept in poor living
conditions with wages withheld so
when we are looking at days of action
and community intelligence uh we do
visit car washes to see who's working
there check their id and things like
that so it's certainly a location we do
focus on
thank you that was really interesting um
i'm wondering how you work with health
providers with particularly on on mental
health i'm thinking but also obviously
people are living in poor conditions and
whatever and you know that their health
is likely to suffer what sort of links
do you have and how do you support
people in that way thank you
thank you it's a very important question
um for those in immediate need of care
those in immediate crisis and immediate
care and control we do have policing
powers to detain them and seek immediate
care for those um but for those who
perhaps in one of those examples say for
example that last scenario where that
mayor was living in poor living
conditions isolated from his community
if we had concerns around his mental
health we would alongside the modern
slavery report create an adult
protection referral which will go to the
centralized team and then that opens the
door to social services mental health
support services and so we will always
share relevant information with partners
should we have concerns for adult or
child mental health cases
boy
thank you chair and thank you matthew
for your um presentation i just wondered
um the three examples that you gave were
around um predominantly sort of
restaurant and public what you could say
public places and during the sort of the
lockdowns did you notice um
much of an increase in reporting of
perhaps the ones where it it's i'm gonna
get the phrase wrong
this
what was it domestic serv
that's the one um what you said um did
you notice an increase in the reports of
that because more people were at home so
they might be more
more able to acknowledge what their
neighbours were up to or certain things
in their local neighborhood
thank you
the trouble is with that type of offense
is whilst you're in the home it's
difficult to report much like domestic
abuse um so during lockdown we saw a
decline in the reporting of domestic
abuse
because people didn't have the
opportunity to get out and and
seek sanctuary and report it um i don't
have the data um to hand in relation to
domestic servitude during the lockdown
for example
but i would take an educated guess that
we probably didn't see an increase for
the same reasons around domestic abuse
that the opportunity to report it
is problematic when you're still
remained in the same house and it is an
area that's um
nationally under reported for those
reasons so i can't comment on specific
data but unfortunately
and
i think i was more alluded to rather
than the victims themselves reporting it
but the almost witnesses so the
neighbours in terms of
and also perhaps you know what is there
more that people can do to be more aware
of of it really so how because you said
about the the warning signs to us and
stuff but is there any kind of work
around how do we promote it to the
public is to be more aware about
reporting things like that and noticing
the signs
thank you there was a a national
campaign recently by the national crime
agency around some really useful videos
on their website about those warning
signs um you know who is it that's
actually washing your car who is the au
pair next door that never actually
leaves the house and you can hear the
shouting and
they arrived several months ago
you know in suspicious circumstances and
they've never really been seen again so
there is um material out there to help
people spot those warning signs um but
perhaps that's something
i can take away um to
through our press office and our modern
slavery human trafficking team to see if
there's any more sort of refreshed
media strategy we can put out around
that just to raise
awareness within the community
thank you very much colleagues um chief
inspector do you have any idea how
i know you mentioned earlier that uh
dover tends to be higher because it
might be reported there even though it
didn't happen there
do you have any ideas of how this area
fits with the rest of
east kent or in or west kent if you're
in touch with your colleagues across the
border
thank you so fanat accounted in the last
six months for about 11 of east kent's
uh
figures so that's ashford canterbury
dover foster and thank the five
districts that we refer to when we talk
about east kent and so than it was 11 of
that
i did have some data or do have some
data in relation to north west and east
kent um east kent does have the highest
number of reports um simply uh mainly
attributed to the fact that we have the
port itself at dover and the channel
tunnel where people are intercepted or
we have people
landing on beaches or jumping out
lorries within east division
so they are taken to the ken intake unit
or east kent custody suites whereby they
then report so east kent will always
have that higher proportion but than
itself was 11 of the last six months
thank you
you
you
okay members and guests i think we're
ready to resume uh we now move to the
agenda item number five the budget
2022-23
um and i'll now call upon councillor
david saunders who's going to present
the report for us
thank you
thank you chairman and for the benefit
of committee members who weren't there
on thursday last i'm going to crib the
introduction that i used at the cabinet
meeting because
it does detail some points
that are within the report but you may
find easier if
if i relay them verbally
just a few months back we were
forecasting a significant budget gap
but with a planned and cautious approach
combined with an efficient savings plan
we have been able to balance our budget
despite what may seem like a lengthy and
complicated process this level of
planning is critically important
it's how we continue to deliver the
services that matter to people and
protect and support our most vulnerable
residents
planning our finances in this way means
that we are on the right track for
balance in our budget in the coming
years
our balanced budget position has been
supported in part by the very welcome
additional funding that has been
provided to us by government next year
however
much of this funding is temporary and
therefore this cabinet proposes to use
these monies in a financially sound way
for example we plan to use the extra
one-off new homes bonus windfall to pay
off debt and hence putting us on a solid
financial footing as we prepare for the
reform of local government
funding and the uncertainty this brings
despite the additional funding we have
received it has been necessary to find
budget savings in order to balance next
year's budget
one of our priorities throughout the
budget setting process has been to
protect jobs as much as possible and as
such a key component
of our budget strategy has been to look
for savings from vacant posts i'm
therefore pleased to present savings of
a quarter of a million pounds have been
found from this review
in addition to this we have also found
almost
another four hundred thousand pounds
from further savings efficiencies and
income generation opportunities
finally the proposed increase in council
tax at five pounds per banned d
equivalent property represents an
increase of less than 10 pence for each
household
as i've said this report was considered
by cabinet on thursday last the 13th of
january the overview and scrutiny panel
is invited to comment on the attached
report
if need be the cabinet meeting on the
27th of january 2022 can consider any
views from the panel thank you
council zones thank you very much indeed
for that we've got uh three members
who've asked to speak under rule 20.1 uh
councillors bailey whitehead and ghana
so first of all can i call on councillor
bailey please
thank you
thank you uh council saunders um
uh firstly i'd just like to acknowledge
the fantastic job that's been done by
the finance team it always amazes me how
it always you know always on edge about
getting the um budget balanced and they
always come up with it and um
it's pretty brilliant job they do and uh
and i also appreciate the time they take
to explain it uh very clearly in all the
briefing sessions there's so many
components which have to be considered
in order to balance the budget and i
appreciate that priority has to be given
to the most essential headings however
as a wall counselor i'm also concerned
with fighting the corner of
of my residence my issues that directly
affect them
and this may not seem significant in the
grand scheme of things but
um
i am again banging the bank and banging
the drum about the viking bay lift i did
raise it um i did raise the question of
whether money had been set aside for the
continuing repairs and maintenance of
the viking bay lift which was the
subject of much controversy last year
um i didn't really get a
straightforward answer it was suggested
that money could be provided through
maybe through negotiations with southern
water
but while that's all well and good this
stuff
does seem a bit tenuous and um
in maintaining this important facility
and i'm not sure personally that we
should be relying on potential donations
for running essential services i'd be
much more reassured to see a definite
allocation within the budget itself for
this
vital facility
thank you
councillor wychez please
thank you very much chair
um firstly i'd like to echo councillor
bailey's sentiments in relation to
finance they do
a fantastic job in
very very difficult circumstances at
times and the briefings have been very
much appreciated
however in relation to our proposed
budget i am here tonight to argue for an
investment of the majority of the new
homes bonus into the purchase of
property to extend our in-house
temporary accommodation service
on several grounds and all costed within
our current budget with no extra expense
i'm confident of my argument and of the
necessity of bringing it
it was argued by cabinet in the last
cabinet meeting that ring fencing money
to pay down non-urgent debt is the most
fiscally responsible thing to do
but what i wish to discuss is that
fiscal responsibility is far more
complicated than simply looking at debt
at 0.310 in the cabinet papers from the
meeting on the 13th of this month
we discuss the ongoing pressures of
temporary accommodation and homelessness
pressures that are now even more severe
due to cuts at a county level which the
leader has herself acknowledged to the
extent of writing a letter to explain
what a significant impact these cuts
could have
and to insist that it is essential that
they are reversed
in light of this it is even more urgent
to consider how we can address our needs
for temporary housing and homelessness
services long term
all members of our previous labour
administration are now very experienced
councillors
moreover the only councillors within our
chamber who had to make complicated
social and fiscal decisions during the
first wave of a pandemic
we have known and experienced
extraordinarily complicated situations
and have learned local governance to a
significant level of detail both due
both to commitment and to the
circumstances under which we served
that experience has served us well and
has given us insight and understanding
that i believe is worth recognising
the simple narrative is that debt is bad
and that paying it off is good and
sensible this is very true on one level
but local governance is never that
simplistic
the 549 000 pounds that has come from
the new homes bonus is significant in
many ways
it holds particular significance to me
considering that this money has come to
us not vial our guests or random
allocation
it has come to a large extent due to the
extraordinary work of housing
during the period of the labour
administration this grant allocation
covers
housing brought 252 empty homes back
into usage
a huge achievement for this area
contrary to popular belief than it tops
the chart in kent for empty properties
being brought back into usage we are
very good at this and work very hard at
it
this has now been recognized as part of
the new homes bonus
and the hard work of housing has brought
new funding into the council and a
significant amount at that
in a moral and fitting sense it seems
only right that the money that housing
has brought into the council go toward
alleviating some of the extraordinary
pressure on housing both financial and
otherwise
and this proposal does both
in using a significant part of the new
homes bonus to extend our in-house
temporary accommodation service
which was designed and planned to reduce
out of area placements and to reduce the
costs of using private providers for our
temporary accommodation needs
we would not only be recognizing the
outstanding work of our officers
directly
but also saving money in a more concrete
and ongoing way than simply allocating
it to pay down loans that we routinely
acquire at a low rate and that we are
already well accustomed to managing
every householder knows the logic of
this
in not investing further in our in-house
provision
we are in effect choosing to pay private
providers for our essential services
rather than pay ourselves to provide the
same service
rather than providing for ourselves and
investing we are promoting reliance on
external providers
our continuing costs in terms of
providing temporary accommodation are an
ongoing and extraordinary cost
they may not be in accrued debt but they
are a future cost that is ever
increasing and is unlikely to subside as
property and rental costs in than it
rise
while i held the housing portfolio
housing will already look at looking at
the potential to expand our in-house
temporary housing to offset these
ongoing costs and to be able to provide
ongoing local support for our residents
who are unfortunate enough to find
themselves homeless in the current
crisis
a potential property to add to our local
temporary housing has already been
located
and whether it is this property or
another the longer we delay in
purchasing property for this purpose the
more we will be paying out in an ever
increasing market
the realities of this situation are
stark and make it clear which the best
course of action is
as reported by the land registry annual
property inflation over the past year in
margate alone has topped 14.4
if rather than using it to address a
social need now
we set this money aside to pay debts
that are not yet mature at a time of
historically low interest rates we will
in effect be accruing greater debt due
to property price increases
add to this the ongoing costs of
providing private temporary
accommodation not only across this
period but also in the future when this
property would be actively working to
mitigate those costs
and we are not only accruing for further
expenditure but also losing the ability
to pay back into the general fund both
to maintain stock and expand it so that
in the future no resident need be placed
out of area and suffer the disruption
that entails
this is not a debt versus spending
argument
it is in fact a clear demonstration of
how to avoid future debt via safe and
sensible investment
both in our housing and in the future of
our community
especially as modellings of costings
have already been done by this council
and established that in-house temporary
accommodation is cheaper than our
current usage of private providers
that is worth a huge amount to our
community to our residents and
ultimately to us as a council
and this is both logical and factually
supported
i have seen it argued that is
disrespectful to officers in putting
forward this proposed amendment
i argue the opposite
not only is this process i have always
respected and consulted with officers on
policy and proposals
so not only do i know this to be a
feasible way forward i also know that in
using the majority of the new homes
bonus for housing
we are directly recognising the efforts
of officers that brought this funding
into council in the first place
as well as directly serving our
residents and reducing the distress that
covert and financial changes have caused
to our community
this is not and should not be a
political decision
it is a logical financially sound and
socially and fiscally responsible one
and i hope very much the overview and
scrutiny discuss it in such a way
our residents would want us to
and our ability to make unified
decisions based on practicality rather
than politics is why we are here and
what we are elected for
i thank you and thank the chair
councillor whitehead thank you very much
indeed that was a very detailed uh
argument and
well made from where you're sitting um i
wonder if i might ask you this might be
slightly unusual but um uh councillor
bailey equally well made point but a lot
shorter
um and can be noted i wonder if a
recommendation is made to council to
consider
the points that you've raised would you
be able
under those circumstances to provide
a written copy of what you've had to say
so that everybody who's considering it
can actually
remember it all and more effectively
discuss it so if it is brought forward
would that would that be doable
yes of course thank you thank you very
much thank you very much councillor
ghana
thank you chair and um of course like
councillors bailey and whitehead
i am thank the the finance team for all
the hard work they've done
uh producing this budget
and also the portfolio holder who i'm
sure has worked very hard with them to
to do this as well
i've got a couple of points i'd just
like to raise i hope you might consider
in any discussions
the first of these relates to
the purchase of electric waste vehicles
which has proved to be discussed on a
number of occasions
and on each occasion
we've been told that we currently we
don't currently have the infrastructure
at the depots to support them
i hope we'll all agree that we will both
want and need to do this as soon as
possible
um so i'd like to
ask or like
you to consider asking what work has
been started in terms of minimum putting
together a business plan for the
implementation of the required
infrastructure
and ask if required some funding be put
aside to enable that to happen
i know a number of other councils in
kent
including swale
are commencing use of electric waste
vehicles this year
i'm sure there's information that can be
gleaned from those that are ahead of us
in doing this
um another area i'd like
to be considered is obviously the
generation of income from other sources
um
and one sauce that's already been
mentioned of course is southern water
and i know the friends of botany bay and
kingsgate have
persuaded them to fund a little bit of a
few months and i'm sure we all agree
that we as a council
um and the leader will continue to seek
much greater reparations from them to
fund services along the coastline that
they've so badly damaged
um and as well as these maybe including
new
toilet blocks along the coast
there are also some maybe
ultimately self-funding
um initiatives that
any funding could be used for
i maybe coastal wardens to enforce our
pspo
which could become self-funding and um
enforcement functions relating to litter
and fly tipping which i know was
discussed at full council recently
and lastly
i'd um i'd like us to consider something
a number of other councils including
bristol city council have done which is
that after initially setting up a small
fund of up to 100 100 000 to train up
maintenance staff to fit heat pumps
solar panels etc in council properties
something that i know we're looking to
do
they've then gone on to use external
apprenticeship levy funds to take on
more staff
and expand what would ultimately become
a self-sustaining service which as well
as obviously
improving our our housing stock in terms
of
the climate emergency also would be able
to provide some new jobs as well
so thank you
council ghana thank you very much
do any members wish to raise any points
for discussion from either of our
speakers
counselling
thank you chair um so the labour group
would like to put forward um the
following motion
um
i'm okay chair to hand out physical
copies of the motion
be easier to read thank you
yeah i've got one thank you yeah yep
yes of course thank you
um
so this motion
looks to address
as council whitehead has already
mentioned urgent housing needs
but not only that climate change
um providing more provision for
the climate emergency which we've
declared
and
addressing councillor bailey
and council ghana's point of fixing
public lifts um so
i'll talk i'll tell i'll read the motion
first
um the oven scrutiny panel invites
cabinet to adopt the following budget
amendments
allocate up to 125 000 pounds from the
new homes bonus allocation for the
capital works required to the ramsgate
east clift and viking bay coastal lifts
to ensure they're in full working order
for the foreseeable future
number two allocate the full remainder
of the new homes bonus
allocation as capital to provide
additional in-house temporary housing
accommodation
and lastly transfer 200 000 pounds from
the risk management reserve to a new
climate risk and opportunity reserve
so let me just briefly explain
this motion
as always already highlighted here
tonight there is a new homes bonus
allocation
of funding worth 549 000 pounds
and we believe that using
this to pay off debt does not create
best value for tdc
um and the majority can spend can be
spent where it belongs as council
whitehead has already said this is
housing
we believe that this money can be
invested in new temporary housing
accommodation to reduce the high ongoing
costs that the council must pay for
providing temporary accommodation to
private landlords
this makes good financial sense and we
believe it pays for itself
in addition with the new homes bonus
funding we have listened to residents
and believe that up to 125 000 pounds
should be allocated to repair the viking
bay and round gate lifts that are much
needed for our disabled and elderly
residents
onto the climate change
reserve
so the creation of a climate change risk
and opportunity reserve
is one that would allow tdc to be bid
ready for future grant climate
opportunities
and would enable
grants when
and hopefully
definitely hopefully when provided would
enable
internal project management which is
much required in council when grants are
awarded
so on this climate change reserve let me
just highlight these important points
no new money is required we are taking
200 000 pounds from risk management
reserve
and putting it into a climate risk and
opportunity reserve
we are enabling our climate
engaged officers to tap into funding to
allow them to access
um this
reserve however each
but using this reserve still requires
the relevant internal sign-off
um lastly climate change as we all know
is a real risk to the council
and maximizing our grant income will
lead to a reduced cost in the future we
believe
and that's the motion we'd like to
propose tonight thanks
thank you very much
just
for clarity please um are you
recommending to the members of the panel
that we take this on board and send it
back to cabinet
for them to consider or are you
suggesting that this is
an amendment to the budget because i'm
not quite sure you can do that point of
all the chair you can't amend we can't
amend the budget here so it can only be
a recommendation hence hence the
question i just wanted clarity thank you
councillor everett
um
so members um
yes councillor
um and i'll speak to it if that's um
agreeable to you um
i think um first of all i'd like to
congratulate councillor whitehead and
councillor yates on their speeches i
think they've been very clear
and um
i think everybody has heard the passion
that councillor whitehead brings to this
particular issue not just tonight but
previously
and i think it's an excellent proposal
and it's clearly contained in the labor
motion
we have
engaged in this process in the
appropriate way
this is the right place for us to bring
forward uh proposed budget amendments
and indeed um the auditors previously
remarked that there is a need for
challenge to take place in the public
forum not behind the scenes it's app
we've had some excellent briefings um mr
blundell gave a great briefing to the
labour group which we very much
appreciated and we have worked with
officers behind the scenes on each of
these proposals so we are satisfied that
they are robust and viable and could be
introduced into the budget
without any any problems and tonight we
are asking cabinet to consider them at
its meeting following this um
following tonight subject obviously to
the support of the scrutiny committee so
i say to the scrutiny committee we are
asking
you to put these as proposals for
cabinet to consider
and i think that would be the proper way
for us to do it on a cross-party basis
so that they go to cabinet obviously
it's up to the scrutiny committee to
decide whether they support these
proposals but i hope you all agree that
this is the proper way for us to conduct
the business of the council and i'm not
going to dwell on
um what councillor whitehead and
councillor yates have already said but i
will say something about the ramsgate
lift which won't surprise any of you
i think that um along similar lines to
what councillor bailly has said about
the viking baylift there has been lack
of commitment to uh bringing that lift
back up to standard back into use and i
understand that part of the reason for
that is is financial it's because the
cost of doing so to the rams gate lift
is more significant than perhaps than
doing it to the viking bailiff lift and
i just want to say that whilst i think
that the viking bay leaflet which we
absolutely support as part of this
proposal
is very important in terms of access to
the beach i think the rams gate eastly
east cliff lift is an iconic structure
which is dear to the heart of many
people in ramsgate
and which cannot be left
neglected and out of use in the way that
so much of our infrastructure
in the past has been due to uh financial
financial difficulties financial
shortages so it is a priority the public
has shown that in the petitions and
other representations that they brought
to the council
i understand that cabinet may have ideas
about other ways of funding these things
and that's fine but what we want to do
is create a budget
as part of this process which gives some
certainty to the people of ramsgate that
this issue is going to be addressed and
the proposals are framed with a certain
amount of flexibility as to the amount
of money
in order that cabinet and officers can
bring
their judgment to that
so i very much hope that
the scrutiny committee tonight will
support these proposals and i hope that
cabinet will take them seriously and
engage in them on a cross-party basis
because that's the way we should do
business as a council thank you
thank you very much councillor members
any other comments check uh council
austin please
thank you chair um i'm
personally
very interested in the um proposals
around the new homes bonus and it it
makes logical sense to me obviously i
haven't seen all the figures and so on
but it makes logical sense that we
should use that money to invest in in
housing provision um also as a ram
skater i'm very keen to see the armscape
lift um
refurbished although i rather suspect
that the amounts of money that will be
required will be way in excess of what
we're looking at here
uh but but you may have more detailed
information on that than i have
um i'm i'm very much hoping that the
proposal around the the climate reserve
would encompass some of the proposals
that the green group has been looking at
um uh that council ghana mentioned um
and and if that were to be the case then
then i would be thoroughly behind these
recommending these suggestions to to
cabinet
any other comments
counseling
thank you i obviously support
what has already been said but i just
wanted to highlight as well
is it making financial sense to invest
in our in extra temporary housing
because of the costs we're paying out
for that there's also
um a sort of emotional
cost to the families when they are moved
out of areas which i've come across
particularly in case work lately so i
think it is a very important field for
us to invest in thank you
um
you've heard the comments that have been
made would you like to respond we have
the proposal put and seconded members
have commented would you like to respond
to anything that you've heard yes i
certainly would um thank you for the
motion
thank you for the presentations i
on behalf of the cabinet
i can confirm that we will take these
away and give them serious consideration
obviously we need to get into dialogue
with the finance team
it was intimated that we had a strategy
and we have been working on a strategy
with regards to the left
the the leader has been working very
closely
on that and
to be fair it was hinted that it did
involve
the town councils and other stakeholders
so we'll need to look at the situation
that you've presented
seriously
what i would say is that we
were
looking at a significant budget gap that
we're looking to close
not only in the forthcoming financial
year
but with regards to future years
and
obviously we need to sit back consider
what she proposed and look at
the overall situation
what i would say is that it's not where
you start it's where you finish and we
need to consider all of the other
elements
that we've been discussing with finance
that go into the monies that we've
allocated in specific positions but we
will take this away and give it serious
consideration thank you
thank you councillor soldiers for your
willingness
thank you chair are we not supposed to
vote on these proposals we're not
supposed to vote on these proposals
first
yeah and there are three there are three
items here
that perhaps
some of us may agree with
a and b and not c and
all combinations thereof so we'll be
voting separately for these three
different issues thank you chair
dear thank you council piper um i was
just about to say
thank you for your willingness i think i
got that far thank you for your
willingness for cabinet to have a look
at this and consider
there are the three and presumably that
being the proposal uh from
uh
council eights and seconded by council
over that you would look at all three of
them but i do need to ask members if you
agree
to forward this proposal as it's been
printed and shared with us and also not
forgetting
uh uh councillors ghana and bailly's
contribution linked to these do you do
members agree to forward this to cabinet
for their formal consideration at their
meeting next week you can have a show of
hands please
apparently i missed your hand councilor
curry
i'm sorry
basically
all right yeah i was i'm just going to
say that i believe the uh the new homes
bonus is an opportunity for the council
to improve these particular
proposals put forward um and i support
the motion thank you
thank you very much uh hands again
please just so we can make it for more
those against
any abstentions
it is agreed cabinet will look at this
at their next meeting thank you very
much for all the contributions
chair could i
were there any other comments that
members wished to make
on
item number five
yes please chair um i just wanted to
pick up um following the the mention
that council ghana made about previous
comments that the green group had made a
cabinet about ways of
generating more income i just wanted to
make sure that the recommendation that
we had made about working more closely
with town and parish councils obviously
that's come up with regard to the lift
but that's about finance we were talking
more about delegation of work and
activity to town and parish councils
some of whom are very keen to work more
closely with
the district council and might be able
to do work more cheaply or more
effectively as being more local
we'd like those recommendations um still
to be born in mind i realize that this
can't be a formal proposal but
we are a little concerned that in the
euphoria that
follows the balancing of the budget and
the greater income than we had expected
those sensible and pragmatic suggestions
may be forgotten so alongside getting
the most we can reparations from
southern water and generating uh income
from other sources we really would
recommend that that cabinet bear those
possibilities in mind as well and pursue
that as a course of action thank you
could i just ask a question please
council austin the um
is the suggestion that town and parish
councils might do it
cheaper
than the council currently pays either
its own stuff
or outsourcing
um and does it rely on
the district council
giving the money to the town and parish
councils for them to do it
or would it be anticipated that those
councils would have to
increase any
uh council tax raising powers that they
have in order to be able to pay for it
i'm sure if that's a complicated no i
quite understand i think what we're
suggesting is that that whole area be
explored further
different possibilities obviously as you
know ramsgate town council already does
a considerable amount of work that
senate district house used to do some of
that is formally delegated some of that
is simply picked up because senate
district council does not have the
capacity to do all the work that is
required in ramsgate so i think what
we're asking for is a closer working
relationship with town and parish
councils and exploring other possible
ways in which work might be shared to
the benefit of all
thank you
call me on the hop there um thank you
very much yes um
cam that can take it away and indeed i
can confirm that the leader and cabinet
are currently in
a number of conversations with the
corporate director of communities with
regards to
a number of elements some of which
you've covered there
so we'll certainly take that away and
carry on with those dialogues
thank you
thank you very much council saunders
again showing the willingness of the
cabinet to have a have a further look uh
council austin are you content to accept
that as a response or did you want to go
through the process of a formal motion
all right
thank you very much i think that
concludes agenda item
number five thank you everybody for all
the contributions and the discussion
thank you also
i know it's been said a few times
already to the finance team and the
portfolio holders and all those who've
got
you know elbow deep in trying to get
this to work thank you for your
work so far and no doubt still work to
do before we
sign off the budget later on
uh
this year so is there anybody who's here
now whose
work is done who might like to go
okay
yes i'm just checking that in case
anybody wanted to to go okay then we
moved to agenda item number six which is
the hra
bundle uh council of saunders i guess
you're presenting this for us again this
evening as well chairman i thought you
were offering me the opportunity to
leave the meeting
this is a covering report we have before
you this evening
which covers next year's hra budget
and that is underpinned by a 4.1 percent
increase in rent for next year the
majority of which i am reliably informed
will be covered by increased benefit or
universal credit payments to our tenants
this rent increase is needed to continue
to drive the hra to a balanced and
sustainable financial position and also
to finance our ambitious house building
program and how the housing investment
plan which obviously we need to take
into account the emotion that has been
presented for to us this evening in that
term in that consideration
the report was
considered by cabinet on the 13th of
january and the overview and scrutiny
panel are invited to comment on the
attack report if need be again the
cabinet meeting on the 27th of january
2022 can consider any views from the
panel thank you
thank you very much members we've got
any comments
for councillors honors on gender item
number six
thank you very much thank you councillor
saunders once more
agenda item number seven then the review
of the overview and scrutiny panel work
program uh do any members have any
comments they'd like to make about the
work program i think most of us are
fairly familiar with it now over the
last few months any additions or
comments
members would like to make
thank you very much
and the gender item number eight then is
the forward plan and exempt cabinet
report list
anything the panel would like to raise
on the gender item number eight
thank you very much everyone well that
concludes the business for tonight's
meeting i declare the meeting closed at
ten minutes past eight and the live
stream of this meeting will now conclude
thank you everybody very much